foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear so you guys know that I was going
to get around to this one sooner rather
than later because if you've been around
here for any length of time uh I
reviewed the novel that this was based
on and I loved it uh probably like
several months ago and not too long ago
if you uh go over to my scare Salon
Channel I also picked this novel as one
of my favorite horror novels of the 21st
century so far and that novel of course
is Grady hendricks's my best friend's
exorcism which came out in 2016 and it
is an amazing novel if you haven't read
it so when I found out
that Amazon Studios was making a film
adaptation of it I was kind of like
I don't know I don't know how I felt I
was kind of like cautiously excited but
also had a lot of trepidation because I
was pretty sure like just the way that
the book is I was pretty sure that any
movie version of this novel was going to
not live up to because I mean it would
be hard to because the novel is so good
I mean the novel is just this
brilliantly realized perfect balance of
horror like grotesque body horror as
well as like actual scary [ __ ] with
comedy like you know it's also funny and
it also is genuinely heartfelt like so
much so I think I mentioned this on my
book review that
um I actually kind of like teared up at
the end because the end was like kind of
Bittersweet so I felt like all of that
stuff that I loved about the book I
didn't think they were going to be able
to you know kind of mimic it in any
meaningful way on screen because I just
kind of feel like the strength of the
movie were probably just too just I
don't know it just I didn't think they'd
be able to replicate it and it actually
makes me a little bit sad to say this
but my suspicions about the movie
adaptation were mostly correct and I'm
not saying this is a bad movie it's not
um it is like a really fun just kind of
like entertaining Little slice of 80s
retro awesomeness it has like some rad
Tunes in it Culture Club aha stuff like
that and uh very very amusingly
atrocious though period accurate
Fashions one of the funniest things in
this was that the girl who played Glee
uh was she had these earrings that were
like these little fuzzy I think they
were little blue bunny rabbits and I
flipped out because I forgot I think
when when I was a kid either I had or my
friend had I can't remember earrings
that were just like that except they
were little brown fuzzy teddy bears but
it looked like the same company made
them and I was like holy [ __ ] I forgot
all about this so I thought that was
like really funny that like one of the
girls had those on because I had
completely forgotten about that little
that little fashion thing there so it
does have good things about it I have
seen reviews calling it like stranger
things but with an exorcism and that's
sort of accurate I mean I think stranger
things is a lot better but it's kind of
like a similar Vibe you know what I mean
so the movie I kind of feel like while
it is fun and it is entertaining it's
mostly just very shallow which is kind
of what I was afraid was gonna happen
and it also leans a lot more heavily on
the comedy than it does the horror and
tones down the book's gruesomeness
pretty significantly because I mean the
book had some really really [ __ ] up uh
like disgusting stuff in it and this one
is just like mildly disgusting you know
what I mean they did like kind of pull
back on the horror a lot which I think
was probably a mistake now just as in
the novel
the story revolves around 16 year old
Abby Rivers who is played by Elsie
Fisher I guess she got a Golden Globe
nomination for the 2018 movie 8th grade
which I've heard was great but I haven't
seen yet and the girl that plays like
her kind of ride or die best friend
Gretchen Lang is played by uh Amaya
Miller and I think she was in she's been
at a few things but I think she was in
uh War for the Planet of the Apes like
from 2017. she looked familiar but I
couldn't like uh quite Place her now
unlike the book the movie takes place
entirely in 1988 when the girls are 16.
the novel actually started out in 1982
and took time to like set up the two
girls meeting as ten-year-olds and kind
of delineating their blossoming
friendship over the subsequent four
years and then most of the book takes
place in 1988 obviously the movie didn't
really have time to do that but I think
it kind of like suffered a little bit as
a result I get that there are time
constraints uh you know with a movie
obviously that you don't have with a
book but I kind of feel like that's the
reason that maybe this book in
particular would have made a better
series than a standalone film I mean I
guess that's true of like the majority
books of books really I feel like this
story has so much more impact when you
really kind of feel the weight of these
two characters long relationship their
long friendship and they're just like
Fierce undying love for one another and
loyalty toward one another it's like it
has a lot more impact and in a movie you
can't really establish that I mean you
can but this movie didn't really do that
you know what I mean so the movie jumps
pretty quickly into the first inciting
incident which is pretty much the same
as it was in the book you got Abby and
Gretchen the two main characters and
then they have two other you know
friends slash classmates they're a
little click or whatever uh Margaret
he's played by Rachel ogechi canoe and
um kanu I guess and Glee who's played by
Kathy Ang uh they're spending the
weekend at Margaret's parents lake house
and they kind of start [ __ ] around
with a Ouija board and then they drop
some acid which has been brought by
Margaret's obnoxious chode of a
boyfriend Wallace who's played by
Clayton Johnson who's really
I kind of wish he'd gotten killed but no
you know what I mean I don't think he
got killed the bucket I can't remember
um so nobody feels any put any like uh
particularly momentous effects from this
LSD so they're all just like is this
even real LSD did you like bring us some
like [ __ ] here but at some point
during the night there's kind of like a
little bit of an argument
Abby and Gretchen kind of end up going
off by the wood into the woods like by
themselves and they end up exploring
this old abandoned house that's kind of
been the subject of like some urban
legends about I think it was like about
a local girl who was sacrificed or
something like that they don't go a huge
amount into it into in the movie so the
girls are in this house and they hear
start hearing like weird noises and they
see some kind of like unsettling [ __ ]
while they're in there although
obviously they think well we're just you
know we're we're on acid so we're
obviously like seeing things but then
like something really bad like kind of
Spooks them and Abby runs off now she
thinks that Gretchen is right behind her
because there's like you know you're led
to believe that like the demon is like
making her just like I'm right behind
you keep running Abby you know what I
mean so it's that kind of thing so she
doesn't realize she's not back there
Gretchen meanwhile uh is not actually
right behind Abby and it's still in the
house and she gets kind of like dragged
into the darkened bowels of this house
by this you know something unseen uh and
but she still hears Abby's voice as
though Abby is like in the house and
like can't find her he's like Gretchen
where are you I'm just right here blah
blah so you know it's kind of like set
up like that where they get separated so
obviously Abby uh you know comes across
the other two girls who have been like
looking for them so they go back to the
house and they find Gretchen in the
house and she's like crying and freaking
out uh they all just think she's
tripping balls and she's seeing stuff so
they don't really think that much more
about it as The Story Goes On though
after this incident uh it's pretty clear
that something terrible happened to
Gretchen in that house
um because subsequently she starts to
act like completely different like
before you know she had kind of like her
Aqua Net her hair game was like totally
on point like her clothes were totally
on point now she's kind of like
neglecting her hygiene and her fashion
sense and everything like that
um she starts to kind of like go real
pale and have the kind of like cold
sores on her mouth and stuff
um starts like mouthing off to the nuns
at their private school like doing all
kind of like rebellious [ __ ] also she
starts to kind of deliberately try to
set her friends against one another by
doing [ __ ] like planting fake love notes
pretty like very openly flirting with
Margaret's boyfriend like right in front
of her
um and basically like saying really
cruel things that Target her friend's
deepest insecurities so you know she's
trying to cause like dissension within
the friend group now despite being the
butt of Gretchen's uh you know some of
her most vicious kind of little uh
machinations or whatever Abby persists
in her efforts to help her best friend
she's really the only one that sticks by
her and knows something is the matter
and she's going to get to the bottom of
it and help her
um so she knows obviously that something
is wrong but she doesn't know what and
Gretchen won't really tell her other
than just like really really sketchy
details she starts to suspect as you
probably would in real life that
Gretchen was maybe raped in the
abandoned house and is acting up because
she's having like PTSD and she can't
tell anybody so since she believes this
she doesn't really want to do it but she
kind of goes behind Gretchen's back like
time it kind of doesn't end run around
her and tells Gretchen's parents and
some of the teachers at school like what
happened and it's like you know hey she
needs some help like that's why she's
acting like this but predictably like
all the authority figures just much like
in the book were all very hypocritical
and they kind of just cared more about
the fact it's like oh my God Gretchen
was doing illegal drugs like more than
the fact that you know she'd possibly
been attacked and was like experiencing
trauma you know what I mean and like I
said I lived through the 80s so this
tracks it that was that was very much
probably what would have happened in
real life so Abby uh finally she has no
one in her life that she can trust so
out of desperation she eventually joins
forces with this ridiculous man this
like very like faith-based bodybuilder
guy uh named Christopher lemon he's
played by Chris Lowell now he's one of
like this Trio of Brothers who do these
really silly like religious revival
shows mixed with weightlifting Feats
like look we're lifting you know waits
for the Lord and [ __ ] like that
um so they do shows that's like private
schools and malls and [ __ ] and as I said
I grew up in the 80s like I said I was
about I think it was exactly the same
age as these girls would have been like
in 1988 I was in high school in 1988 so
having grown up in the 1980s I didn't go
to a private school I just went to a
regular public school but I do remember
these kind of events were kind of a bit
of a thing like at religious schools
particularly because I knew some people
that went to religious schools and did
these kind of ridiculous like I said you
know pumping up your faith kind of it
was always like some kind of stunt like
you know what I mean that had to do but
they would like attach Jesus to it and I
remember like the weightlifting ones
being like particularly there was like a
lot of those now despite this guy being
a complete and total doof who kind of
reminds me he kind of reminded me a
little bit of like 80s Rob Lowe a little
bit like his look I've never he looked
kind of familiar so I don't know if I've
seen him in anything else like I said um
Chris Lowell I should have looked him up
probably but yeah but I but he just gave
me that kind of like Rob Lowe sort of
vibe so like I said he's a total dork
but
um he is the real thing like he does
when he comes to their school like to do
the presentation he sees Gretchen like
sitting in the crowd and like
immediately knows that something's wrong
with her she's like possessed or
whatever Abby ends up going to him and
persuades him to perform an exorcism on
her and he agrees after she is like well
I'll give you like a whole bunch she
works at like a yogurt shop and she's
like I'll give you a bunch of like free
yogurt punch tickets and uh you know and
he kind of wants to take it on too
because he's never done one before and
he wants to like prove to his brothers I
guess that he's capable of doing it and
I guess like their mom died a long time
ago and he has like mommy issues like I
said they kind of go into a bit more in
the book but they kind of like talk
about it in the movie as well so as I
mentioned these are all pretty much the
exact same plot points from the book
like it is a faithful adaptation I'm not
saying that like at least as far as the
plot points and the events that happen
but because the film has to by necessity
compress like a great deal of the story
into it's quite short run time it's only
about 93 minutes something like that the
whole thing kind of felt a little bit
rushed to me and so relationships and
plot points and things like that aren't
really given much room to breathe now
maybe it's possible that the movie
doesn't feel that way to somebody that
hasn't read the novel
um you know I I wouldn't know because I
read the novel and I read it fairly
recently but to me it just did seem like
a lot of the narrative was just kind of
like skimming the surface of what made
the book so special like what made it so
good without all of that backstory and
build up of Abby and Gretchen's
friendship and also to a lesser extent
their relationship with Margaret and
Glee also like the Dynamics of their
friend group all you're kind of left
with without all of that is just this
kind of mildly amusing like 80s set teen
comedy really with kind of just like a
sprinkling of quite mild horror elements
I mean to put that another way there are
already lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of exorcism stories so you
really need to bring something amazing
to the table to make one of them stand
out from the pack now Grady Hendricks
who wrote the novel absolutely did that
um taking all of these kind of tired
exorcism tropes and using them to
explore kind of deeper issues like like
not only the intensity of teenage female
friendships like the love that develops
between them and the loyalty and
everything but also kind of too like the
manner in which girls find themselves
and find their own unique power like as
they grow up it's like a coming-of-age
story
um so when you don't have all of that
and without all of the emotional
investment that you felt with the book
characters which you absolutely do
because the characters are just really
really well uh realized in the book so
without that
um the movie just seems a little bit
like fluff I mean don't get me wrong
it's fun fluff it is very fun and very
entertaining
um and the two lead actresses are
actually great but I kind of wish they
had been given something with a little
bit more substance like to work with I
also kind of wish too that the movie had
tipped the scales more in the direction
of horror rather than comedy I didn't
mind the comedy obviously because the
book was funny too but I feel like the
horror wasn't horrory enough like it
didn't go far enough
um because I kind of feel like one of
the best things about the book was like
the juxtaposition between those two
things which was really really well done
now I admit that in the movie I did
laugh out loud like the Exorcist because
he was so ludicrous and yet somehow like
still kind of lovable uh and that was
like a definite highlight of the movie's
third act
um his character was also hilarious in
the book I might add and it does
translate very well here like into the
movie but I felt like I wanted more body
horror like the one in the book like the
thing with the tapeworms which they get
into here but is not nearly as gross as
it was in the book like it's hardly
gross at all like seriously which kind
of like bummed me out uh so I wanted
more of that body horror that gruesome I
wanted more creepiness because the book
is actually quite creepy and like has
some like really scary bits in it even
though it's also funny
um and I kind of wanted more of a sense
of like the stakes at play in the book
you really because so much time has been
spent like establishing these characters
and getting you really emotionally
invested in them there the stakes seem
like really really high and you're
really kind of like rooting for Abby to
be able to save Gretchen you know what I
mean and because they didn't have time
to do that in the movie and it's just
like kind of shallow like the characters
are fine but they're not you don't get
the sense of this deep like long
friendship and they're complete and
utter like loyalty toward one another
and like when one of them starts acting
this way and like Abby just refusing to
give up on her like it was like so
awesome in the book and like the stakes
were like really really high but in the
movie you didn't really feel that and
that's like kind of like a shame
so the movie like I said it's fine
um I got the sense that it was aiming
for a much younger demographic which
there's nothing wrong with that
obviously but I think that the novel
sort of transcended that I think the
novel kind of went above and beyond
considerations of age or gender or era
like the area you grew up in like
everybody could relate to it in some way
and I'm not sure that the movie really
achieves that same universality it just
seemed like it was very much going
toward maybe not even a PG-13 it just
seemed like it was just very very mild
and I just kind of feel like I wish it
would have taken more of a stand and put
more Horror in it and put more into the
character development even if they'd had
to made the movie a little bit longer
that would have been fine too but like I
said if you haven't read the novel I'm
sure it you'd probably find it like
pretty entertaining although keep in
mind like I said I do feel like it's
aimed toward a slightly younger audience
like a teenage audience maybe but I mean
like I said not there's anything wrong
with that it just came across as a
little why a and I kind of wish they had
gone more like the book you know I mean
more like the tone of the book even
though the movie has all of the same
plot points but the tone is a lot
different so just know that going in so
you know I didn't love it but it was fun
it was like a fun enough time I just
kind of wish that I could approach it
like more open-mindedly I guess because
you know having read the novel and
having loved the novel so much uh you
know any probably any movie if it was
going to be a disappointment so I don't
want to [ __ ] on it too much for that but
you know that's how it goes and it's on
Amazon Prime uh if you want to check it
out if you haven't read the novel and
you watch the movie and you know I'd be
curious to hear your opinions on it
because I don't you know I can't have
that experience obviously because I read
the novel like pretty recently but I'm
curious to see uh how other people
reacted to it as well so that will do it
for this flickers of fear and I will see
you guys again on the next one bye